Hi guys, I'm erik bosse, and I think we can all agree that Dr.
Strange was just pure ridiculous [cumber] fun
But a lot of you guys been asking about the movies ending and yeah the whole movie can be a bit of a mine good
[times], but the [Endian] is an especially aggressive [mind] like Dr.
Strange enough my brain has to work in the morning, [so] in this video
I'm Gonna Explain
exactly what went down in that final dark dimension
Sequence of the movie and why it was so brilliant when he put it all together with a bunch of little clues that came up
throughout the film I'm also Gonna explain
Why [wang] revealing the eye of Agamotto as an infinity stone is so important and by the way if you want to know what happens
In the post-credits scenes I did another video that covers all [of] that this video is like a pre credit scene Breakdown
I know it's crazy someone actually wants to talk about what happens before the credits of a marvel movie
What world are we living in here [ok] bear with me as I take a step back, but in order to understand Dr.
Strange's ending you have to accept that this entire movie is about time, and yeah, sure it's about a lot of other things, too
Broken position trying to heal himself so that he can heal and save others letting go of pride and ego mind over matter
hands, but above all this is a story about a man struggling with time controlling his life and that by freeing himself from [time] he
Can use time to his advantage so that basically as the beatles put it time?
Is a yellow submarine I'm pretty sure that's how it goes throughout the film this idea of time is
Represented in the recurring symbol of a clock so like in the early scene doctor strange is operating on a gunshot victim
racing against time to remove a bullet from his brain and notice how when he tries to focus he's
Distracted by the ticking of Dr.
West's Wristwatch
And then he snaps at him to cover it up to block the sound now why does this ticking derail strange like this see at
This moment strange is at the Peak of his pride
He's a brilliant surgeon
Nailing this miraculous surgery that only he can do and the best of all he's rubbing it in the face of his rival he feels
invincible but the ticking of the watch
Reminds him that he's not invincible
[he's] mortal his own time is running out strange is kind of like a reverse
Captain hook like he's driven mad by a ticking sound that will soon
Foreshadow a life changing hand injury strange hates to be reminded
how time is controlling his life another clock that keeps showing up throughout doctor strange is the watch given to him by
Christine Palmer and remember that shatters when the muggers in Katmandu tried to steal it now notice
How [that] break happens right before he meets carl [mordo] and the ancient one and he begins his training and [Kamar] tosh
That's a symbolic moment of character growth for strange
He's literally breaking time diverging from his old [timeline]. Which was trying to heal his hands and [continue]
His [life] the Surgeon and now he's going to this new [timeline]
outside of time breaking the laws of Nature and learning the mystic arts
Okay
now [fast-forwarding] a bit here at the end of his training strange uses the book of cagliostro in the eye of [a] [komodo] to
manipulate time which is represented by this apple going back and Forth between
Eaten and uneaten and when wang and [mordo] catch them in the Act
mordo [warned] strange about paradoxes and time loops with this foreshadowing line
Do you want to get stuck reliving the [same] moment over and over forever and then strange is like, huh?
You don't say that could [be] useful okay fast-forward him again here while battling Kycilia
strange learns that the [dark] [dimension] is a place Beyond time Cai sillies opera strange what he thinks he wants the freedom from
Mortality to no longer worry about his time ticking away notice
How strange seems to consider this guy sillies tries to drive the point home by saying time and slaves us time as an insult death?
Is an insult but then later strange?
realizes the truth while talking with the ancient one in the astral plane at the moment of her death her philosophy is the opposite of
Cai silius she says death is what gives life meaning?
To know your days are numbered [your] time is short
so finally arriving at the end here in this final showdown in Hong Kong
Strange puts all of this knowledge about time together
[he] sees that the sanctum has already fallen and Kycilia says opened the gate [of] the dark dimension
How strange knows that he can reverse time to save the city using spells in the eye of agamotto?
But he knows that Kycilia is stronger than him and he probably can't feed him so he remembers two things one the [dark] [dimension] is
A realm where time does not exist, [so] by introducing time into it that would give strange a huge advantage and then to
Tampering with time can result in creating a loop reliving the same moment over and over forever
So that's what happens when strange floats up into the dark dimension
he creates a time loop starting with him proposing the bargain to dormammu and ending with his [debt] and because
Dormammu has no understanding of time. He's trapped in this until strange decides to stop it
So just like in movies like groundhog day
Or edge of tomorrow [doctor] strange dies and resets over and over
I personally counted 12 times
and he does this until dormammu goes crazy and strange eventually breaks him and convinces him to leave this room and take high silius and
his followers with him and what I love about the sequence is just like bill murray and groundhog day and Tom cruise and edge of
Tomorrow it's implied that doctor strange could have died hundreds thousands
maybe an infinite number of times
Notice how strange invited death regardless of how painful it would be saying
pain is an old friend and you gotta imagine that like dormammu would have enjoyed finding new ways to kill him for at least the
First couple hundred times until he got bored
And then maybe another thousand before it became like Mildly annoying and then thousands infinite number of times more before it became
legit torture
And it's really satisfying to see doctor strange show that he understands the ancient ones words that death is what gives life meaning?
Literally [doctor] strange's death or rather his infinite number of Deaths saves all the lives on Earth
Ultimately giving his life meaning once again
And then in these final moments wong of course reveals that the eye of agamotto is an infinity stone
specifically the time stone and that makes sense given the
Godly level power gives strange over time so that makes five out of six infinity stones revealed an McU so far and this officially ties
Doctor strange [to] the upcoming Avengers infinity war movies where thanos will try to assemble all of these stones in his infinity gauntlet
Basically making him ruler of all the universe we're just gonna have [to] imagine how powerful
[Danice] is going to become if he combines the [power] of the tesseract and the ether and [the] mind stone ambitions head and the orb
That Ronan used and now this time stone
[good] luck avengers
But now let's talk about this final shot which connects back to this idea of time strange puts back on [his] broken watch from Christine
If you look closely the way the glass is broken on the watch
Matches up with the lines in the seal of Vishanti in the Sanctum window also this watch wraps around the wrist
Just like the green time spell that we saw so we're seeing that through this broken watch that time is something that no longer in
Slave strange now real quick this video was brought to you by the great people at Warby Parker
They have a selection of really cool frames for your glasses now if you ever catch me like squinting at the camera
it's because I wear
And they get super dried out from these hot lights or you know I run out and I have to wear glasses like that one
Humiliating time a couple [videos] back [now]
I wasn't a huge fan of those frames
And it's always hard to shop [for] new ones because the woman at the store is just like standing right there
And she's like those make you look cool and they [really] don't you just you know wants to make a sale?
And then I fall in love with her and it gets super awkward
But Warby parker is great because they offer a home
Tryon where they send you frames to try on for free on your own with your friends who will be like brutally honest with you?
I love it and since you viewers are my best friends whether you like it or not
I need your help deciding which frames to get so head to warby parker comm slash new Rockstars to see my current favorite frames and
Get started with your free home try on today
You can choose five frames that you'd like to try on mail the frames back choose your favorite pair or pairs to have your prescription
Added to and then order where we parker makes your [experience] completely risk-free
visit Warby parker comm slash new Rock stars to begin your free home try on
Experience today, and when you go to the site comment on which frames that you like best for me?
And you'll be entered to win a $50 gift card to warby Parker will shoot it randomly, but you have to comment
I need your advice
[I'm] an indecisive idiot help me new Rock Star Subscribers. You're my only hope
[alright] if you [liked] this video please hit like and subscribe to new Rock stars
For more of these videos and remember to check out my breakdown of the doctor strange
Post-Credit scenes if you haven't already you can also contribute to new Rock stars on Patreon big
Thanks to all of our current patrons. We love you guys, and you aren't currently contributing to us
You can start right [now] for as little as $1 a month every little bit helps and getting these videos out faster
So thank you guys again
[hit] me up on Twitter a ta boss with any thoughts you have on doctor strange
[or] any cruel jokes you have about [mandating] classes you also go [in] new Rock stars on Twitter at New Rock Stars
And bother them about when our videos are coming out alright. Thanks for watching bye
you